juste pour te parler
non, je ne l'aurais pas fait
route mais il y avait plus, je sais que
tu sais qu'il y avait plus entre
il y avait plus entre nous
on dit quoi pas
Je sais si un baiser est un chien ou un
rose, dis-le, je sais ça
tu sais que ce serait inutile
maintenant utile
à l'heure actuelle mais je cherchais
nous une excuse plus forte pour nous un
excuse plus sérieuse que de pleurer de misère
misère
d'amour
et je voulais Shem
Jamais une raison plus vraie que Sem n'aime jamais
dis que je suis venu pour rester
rester
parce que juste pour te parler
non, je ne l'aurais pas fait
route mais il y avait plus, je sais que
Vous savez
Il y en avait plus entre
nous y étions
de l'autre et je cherchais
nous une excuse plus forte pour nous un
excuse plus sérieuse que de pleurer de misère
misère
d'amour et voulu
donne-moi une raison plus vraie
C'est à moitié comme dire que je suis venu pour
rester
rester avec
moi-même
V